[Music]
let's talk about Rob Delaney the man
alright you
all right and I'm back I'm with you pal
what's you have tweeted about what you
call your unusual taste in women what
are you talking about okay I like real
women I like women I like women who you
know I like women that have hair on
their bodies for example I like women
who have things like cellulite you know
I like women whose body parts go like
slap a NAPA doodle when they walk around
here's the deal I slap adapt the doodles
slap about the doodle now I'm getting
excited I'm six-three I weigh 220 I need
a woman I need like a Williams sister
who can handcuff me to a radiator and
just be like really you know you want a
woman to overpower you a little bit
that's pretty that is what I want yes
and no but seriously I mean things like
I try to mount a little campaign my own
message about like cosmopolitan telling
women shave off the hair melt it off and
like now I keep it and I'll swing by I
like it you know
but like you know I was in a coffee shop
the other day a woman raised her hand
till I can grab a macchiato biscuit I'm
sure and she had a hairy armpit and I
was like oh yeah I had to go out my car
and deal with myself I just like that
hairy armpits like a little commercial
for what's going on downstairs
yes it would be so so so that's what you
like and and you that's good I think
it's a good message for women to hear
don't you
we here's the deal god / science this is
how I address her is did a good job you
know and why should we think that you
need to you know Melbourne it off melted
iron it I don't know how to do it but
don't do that to your body let it be and
I'll as I said swing by you uh Tracy I
like to picture you on a vine yeah a
woman's just about